alright we're not we're not actually
started yet you're a very well behaved
class here using my classes are much
more rambunctious than this well done
and we're going to wait we're gonna wait
a second we're live-streaming this so
I've got to get the guys in the back the
heads up when we're ready to go looks
like burberry go good afternoon my name
is Tom part I'm Dean of the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences and i'd like
to welcome you all to the company of
scholars lectures from the graduate
school for this year this is the first
of four lectures that we're featuring
this year we've got a bit of a theme you
might have to come to all four lectures
to figure out what the theme is but i'll
tell you about jacob hacker our first
speaker just a moment january twenty
second Beverly gauge from the history
department will be speaking on j edgar
Hoover and his role in the founding of
the conservative movement in the United
States on februari 19th Katherine lorem
from religious studies going to be
speaking about the role of religion and
parenting in the US she does
fantastically interesting things and
then on April second paul tipton from
the physics department is going to talk
about whether the world's public have
gotten their money's worth in the search
for the Higgs boson which is a big
physics project in Switzerland he works
on our speaker today is Jacob hacker
Jacob received his undergraduate degree
from Harvard and his PhD from Yale in
the year 2000 he is now professor of
political science a director of
Institute for Social and Policy Studies
here at Yale Jacob is a prolific author
of works dealing with fairness in our
democracy and that's what he's going to
be talking about today I believe he's a
public figure who was prominently
featured in many of the debates about
the health care reform and we're really
thrilled to have a lead off our series
this year we intended to have this
lecture at the end of October to sort of
energized everybody at the end of the
political campaign but superstorm sandy
intervene so we had to literally take a
raincheck here on the lecture but
perhaps now is even a better time for
Jacob to share his thoughts on his
America isn't American politics
undermining the American dream Jacob
Thank
well I'm I'm very pleased to hear to be
here and thank you very much for the
kind introduction whenever you hear
prominently featured you should he said
I was prominently featured in health
care debate you should substitute
viciously attacked but that's okay this
is this is this is why a political
scientists who get engaged in policy
debates you need to have thick skin I
want to thank Dean Pollard i want to
thank Rob and luda sir for helping put
this together and I want to mention the
institution for Social Policy Studies
really briefly because this is a jail
institution dedicated to
interdisciplinary work in the social
sciences that's really focused on
precisely encouraging scholars to do
work that's engaged with pressing policy
debates we're doing a lot I became
director of the institution last year we
have a new graduate policy fellows
program if you're a graduate student and
interested in public policy should look
into it we're also doing a lot of events
in fact we're doing one tomorrow jointly
with the law school on the fiscal cliff
for those who are interested I'm going
to spare you what you've probably been
hearing so much about and actually not
talk too much about the fiscal cliff
debate today but i will i will say a
little bit about it so I'm going to keep
my preliminary remarks relatively short
because I want to be able to delve into
some pretty complicated issues in about
45 minutes and whenever I'm under these
kind of time constraints I'm reminded of
an evaluation that I received when I was
a new assistant professor here at Yale
and it began quite promising Lee it said
professor hacker if I had just 15
minutes to live I'd want to spend them
in your class because that way it would
seem like an hour
okay what I do have I do have one last
thanks I want to thank my co-author Paul
Pierson with whom I wrote
winner-take-all politics this is a book
that has now been out for a couple years
after a year of surfing along in the
high three hundred thousands on Amazon
it was featured on Bill Moyers a new
program on PBS and and managed to
momentarily break into the top 30 on the
New York Times paperback bestseller list
thus according to our pub my publisher i
am now eight York Times bestselling
author forevermore so I'll take what I
can get so I have been waiting to give
this talk for a long time hurricane
sandy of course intervene I'm going to
forego showing you the slide that
occurred that correctly predicted every
electoral college vote because because
it was copied from nate silver's website
okay so enough jokes I want to get to
something that's unfortunately a lot
darker and I will motivate that focus
with a report really excellent report
that came out from the Pew Research
Center a nonpartisan Public Policy
Center late earlier this year the report
showed what most of you who have been
paying attention to the economy and to
our politics know well that is that this
has been an extremely difficult period
and it's not just the Great Recession if
you look over the last 20 or 30 years
this has been a period in which
middle-class wages and incomes have
grown slowly I'll show some more on that
in a moment while the economic strains
facing families in many cases have
increased most most Americans feel as if
inequality is risen not surprisingly and
most who believe that it has gone up do
not think it's a good thing and you know
you the pollsters are picking up this
and perhaps the most I thought perhaps
the most telling moment in recent debate
over our governmental institution came
when Senator Michael Bennet of Colorado
went to the floor and presented
slide that looks something like this
this is the US Congress's approval
rating a sandwich between that of Hugo
Chavez and Fidel Castro I note with some
mirth that Paris Hilton is substantially
more popular than the contemporary
Congress but you don't have to look at
these polls to sense the the era of
concern this election was a nasty and
difficult fight one that perhaps
provided an inspiring n for half the
population or slightly or slightly more
but which was but which came on the
heels of a very difficult period in
American politics one that shows no
signs of changing soon and I think it's
worth stepping back from the debate over
tax and budget policies to look at the
sort of larger longer-term trajectory of
the American dream what I call here the
American Dream which is really by which
I mean really the the basic idea that in
the United States if you work hard if
you play by the rules that you'll be
able to get ahead and that your children
will have a better life then then you
had and this ideas this is so closely
tied up with the idea of the middle
class United States has come under
pretty significant strain and perhaps
the most notable feature of that strain
has been degree to which there seems to
have been a divorce between the income
and wealth of those at the very top and
the rest of Americans it's really
striking and I'll show some figures in a
moment just how concentrated the
economic gains the last 20 or 30 years
have been the top point one percent of
Americans so the richest one in a
thousand taxpaying households have seen
their real incomes more than quadruple
since the 1970s and it's and it's been
increasingly difficult for politicians
to ignore this this central change back
in 2006 hank paulson and the treasury
secretary said I think somewhat
defensively growing inequality is simply
an economic reality and it's neither
fair nor useful to blame any political
party
now you know we we might understand why
Paulson was dismissive he was of course
defending the administration he led and
there was no doubt which party he meant
when he said one was being unfairly or
uselessly blamed but in fact paulson's
view that this is simply a massive
economic transformation I think is the
common view among both popular
commentators and scholars who study
inequality at least until recently it's
certainly been the view among those
who've been on the winning end of these
trends back a year earlier before
Paulson statement in 2005 Sandy Weill
said in the New York Times profile this
is the former head of Citigroup he said
people can look at the last 25 years and
say this is an incredibly unique period
of time we didn't rely on somebody else
to build what we built and in this view
the Titans of Finance who are surfing
the waves of this new global economy are
simply superstars who benefited from an
enlargement of the market shift towards
greater reliance on financial
instruments major changes in our society
they've rewarded talent of the sort the
Sandy Weill possesses so it's worth
knowing that before he was deposed as
head of Citigroup there was a plaque on
the wall of Sandy Wiles office it was
four feet wide apparently wood with a
glass cover and etched in that glass was
a picture of Sandy Weill in his name and
below it it said Sandy Weill Shatterer
of glass-steagall now for those who
don't get the inside reference
glass-steagall is of course the New Deal
regulations who helped whose repeal help
Citigroup form the massive banking
behemoth that in turn health net worth
skyrocket so politics and government
were intimately involved in sandy Wiles
rise and I'll argue are intimately
involved in the rise of the very rich
over the last generation more broadly
now this isn't a story about one party
or a few
bad apples at the top it's a deeper
story about how our democracy has
changed in a sense it's a puzzle inside
a riddle inside a mystery the puzzle is
why American society has become so much
more unequal over the last generation
and in this specific way that I've
already talked about the concentration
of rewards of the at the very top the
riddle and is how as we show in the book
this wasn't just a passive result of
natural inevitable market forces though
forsett market forces played an
important role but also the result of
things that our leaders did and
deliberately didn't do to redistribute
income and remake markets and that leads
of course to the mystery which is how
did this happen right our political
system may not do many things well but
one thing it is supposed to do well and
been set up to do well is to moderate
political forces to ensure that the
middle of the political spectrum and the
middle class has political sway now I'd
like to provide the whole answer to this
these mysteries riddles and puzzles but
I'm not going to be able to i'm going to
give you a sense of some of the clues
that Paul and I discuss in our book and
some of the indictments that we offer
and then I want to spend a little bit of
time talking about where I think this
leaves us in the wake of a tightly
fought election and against a backdrop
of a looming fiscal cliff so the way we
think about inequality I think that we
are ingrained to think about inequality
is about to have not and the haves those
at the bottom who are barely getting by
and the rest of Americans the shift that
I want you to make in your thinking that
will really help if you understand
what's happened is to think instead
about the habit all's at the top and the
rest of Americans we've transformed in
the last generation into a society in
which economic rewards are much much
more concentrated at the top now I'm
going to show you some statistics that
really drive this home they're not from
my own work they're from interpretations
of congressional budget office and IRS
data but but I think they really make
things
I want to warn you since I am going to
show these charts that that I have a
fondness for statistics i guess probably
with this audience that's not as big of
a problem disease as it is with some
others but my defense here came from
Moyers himself who once said that it is
the mark of an educated man to be deeply
moved by statistics so so I hope you
share my passion okay I'm not the only
one who feels this way remember Occupy
Wall Street this rather short lived but
nonetheless explosive political protest
featured signs like this one here since
when have we had a political protest
that use Congressional Budget Office
data to make its point and you can
already see here what I'm going to show
you in a moment this remarkable rise in
the incomes of the top 1% and if you're
just glancing at this you'll notice
right away that this rise with the
exception of these spikes and declines
which reflect mostly the stock market is
very continual over the last generation
that is it's been a feature of our
politics now for about 30 years let me
show you this a little bit more clearly
so here I'm taking the CBO's data and
going back to nineteen seventy-nine the
first year available and this is just on
the left the real incomes of these
different income groups so we have the
lowest through the top the fourth fifth
so that's the 60th the 80th percentile
20th the bottom twenty percent the 60s
to 80s and then I've simply broken the
top 1% out of the 80th to 90th
percentiles since we've been talking
about the bottom ninety nine percent in
the top 1% a lot this is not very
strange but I should say that the time I
was doing this that this is actually not
as commonly done in a lot of the
research and i'll show you that it
matters quite a bit so let's go back to
nineteen seventy-nine we're looking at
real dollars these include all public
and private benefits as best they can
measure them and federal taxes though
not state and local taxes just so you
know state and local taxes have
increased a lot over the last generation
much more than federal taxes and
are more regressive so if anything this
would understate the changes that have
taken place so you can see if you go
back to nineteen seventy-nine the top 1%
had an average income of you know in the
four hundred thousand dollars a year
range and that was much greater than the
middle fifth over here which had an
average income there was more in the 40
45 thousand dollar range but let's
fast-forward to 2007 again real dollars
if the picture is worth a thousand words
or in this case I guess 1.4 million
words this one is it right so what you
can see here is really all groups have
seen some gains the gains have been most
dramatic at the very top and I'll say in
a moment that this in some ways over
under States to transformation since for
the middle and blend these lower groups
a lot of these gains have been too
though not to rising wages but to
increased family work hours that's not
as true at the very top so the top 1%
has seen its scene about more than a
third of all income gains over this
period and really it's even more
dramatic if you look at the 2000s when
over half of all income gains went to
the top 1% but in some ways this is
actually it's hard to believe an
understatement of how concentrated the
games are done what if we just took this
top 1% this group rarefied group that we
talked about so much and broke it into
its various constituent parts so we can
go here from the bottom half of the top
1% all the way up to the top 80 1% this
is nosebleed territory in the income
distribution I think the technical term
for this group is the ordinary rich and
the technical term for this group will
say the stinking rich okay so the top
point 0 1 percent to the bottom half of
the top 1% again 1979 you can see there
is inequality among the top 1% but
what's really striking is again how
concentrated the gains are within the
top 1% so one wonders that the slogan of
Occupy Wall Street might have been
or at least maybe if the vice
president's start watch what marching on
Washington we are the ninety-nine point
nine percent you know we got a little
bit of a taste of this during the
presidential campaign and funnily enough
it was during the Republican primary
I don't think a liberal massachusetts
governor is going to come to be able to
go and go and relate too late to folks
as well as the guy 4head son of a coal
miner but he says that she ten thousand
dollars holy mackerel that's just a lot
of money for those people I guess around
you would like to go back all the money
he's earned for bankrupting companies
and lane los ramones over his years of
pain
I was struck by the political analysis
that of the sheer volume lanta Gingrich
hands run by Romney's back his pack by
his wings that I was advanced the same
things that are false that's somehow
when washington plays the game isn't
that exactly what sick about this
country right now isn't that what the
American people are tired of he's using
the limit knighted by King Florence
rigging the system in some way come to
be believed it at the bottom of believe
in free people on free markets pull back
those regulations that are strangling
the American leadership for more tax
rates considerably on job creators get
government out of the way lower taxes
less regulation and praising the people
bring jobs oh right your platform
your
okay so this this debate during the
Republican primaries I think really
drove home the extent to which there was
even debate about the very very top
pulling away from the rest of the rich
within the top 1% now I was just going
to mention a couple quick things I noted
already that much of the gain in income
for the middle came from increased
family work hours you can see here that
over the last 30 years or so that really
the gains in productivity which were
relatively substantial though slower
than they had been in the previous
generation were not matched by gains and
compensation now there's some issues
with the compensation data but this does
include a benefits you can see that it's
male workers in particular the white
line here so I really no no gains now
and this is true actually surprisingly
high up the educational spectrum so for
example if you look at entry-level male
workers with a college degree their
income gains over the last 30 years have
been relatively modest they're less
likely for for example to have health
insurance at their place of work so
these strains have been have been
actually felt by many Americans who are
actually relatively well educated and
moreover and I think this is the
important point it's hard to reconcile
those really sharp gains at the top with
a model that it's focused just on sort
of generalized return to education right
where you would expect that the games
would be much more broadly diffused so
in general then when people start to
look at what's happening at the top and
I'm going to skip over a couple things
that I think are of interest but
I don't want to take up too much time in
general when you look at what's
happening at the very top you start to
question the sort of the story that is
emphasizing skill what what is often
called skilled biased technological
change by economist but that's it that's
a kind of negative explanation or
negative negative account in the sense
that the skill bias technological change
arguments don't seem to be wholly
consistent with how concentrated the
games have gains have been I want to
provide a moment a much more positive
account that sort of attempts to
attribute many of these changes to
changes in public policy the last clue
in this is that the United States is not
unique but quite distinctive in the
concentration of income at the very top
so it you may be aware that the
economist emmanuel saez and his
colleagues have put together the best
available data across national data on
the concentration of income at the top
based on tax statistics and what they've
done is put these together in the sink
in this source called the world top
incomes database and if you take that
data and you look back in the early
1970s you can see a remarkable
similarity across rich countries in the
share of income going to the top 1% I
should note that these numbers do not
include capital gains which are very
hard to compare across countries that's
a significant oversight as well as I'll
show in a moment capital gains are very
concentrated at the top and they're much
more prevalent in the united states that
in many other rich countries so again if
anything these numbers understate the
difference between the united states and
at least the non Anglo countries you can
see here if we go to the the last year
available in the top incomes database
which is not always the same but that
doesn't change the conclusion much you
can see here that the United States
looks more like the so-called Anglo
countries Australia Canada New Zealand
UK and yet even among those countries
the games at the very top have been much
more market this number including
capital gains in two thousand seven or
so was around twenty-five percent which
was the highest point reached since on
the eve of the
a depression you can see though that a
number of countries have seen small
increases some have seen almost none at
all the United States really stands out
raising the question again of why if
there's broad technological forces at
work across these countries and and that
are increasing the returns of education
the gains have been so much more
concentrated the United States than in
other rich countries now the first
answer to this question is if we these
are most of the figures i've shown you
are in pre-tax to pre-tax data as with
this but i did show you that figure
before the Congressional Budget Office
figure that showed post tax data and so
obviously the first question you would
want to ask is well has government
played a role in tamping down the
inequalities that are occurring in
pre-tax data and the Congressional
Budget Office is answered this question
pretty definitively in a recent report
and you can see here that United States
over the period of rising inequality has
actually done less to reduce the
so-called Gini index through tax federal
taxes and transfers whereas the Gini
index reduced inequality by almost a
quarter sorry whereas taxes and
transfers reduce the Gini index by
almost a quarter in nineteen eight
nineteen seventy-nine the number was
closer to seventeen percent in 2007 with
most of the change occurring because of
the less redistributed quality of
transfers over that period but this is
this suggests that the United States and
and if you look in comparative relief
its distinctive that the United States
did less to reduce inequality but it
doesn't really answer the question of
what happened at the very top according
to the Congressional Budget Office about
half of the rise in the Gini index in
the United States is due to income gains
at the top that is the pulling away of
the top 1% an increasing dispersion of
income within that and if we're going to
try to understand the role of government
in changing inequality in the United
States we're obviously going to have to
look beyond just a taxes and public
transfers or at least the broad effect
of taxes and public trans
first so the first thing to say is that
if we're looking at the top we really
need to ask what were the policies that
affected the top the most and the most
obvious is tax policy so if you go back
to the 1960s here and this is from data
that comes from saez and Poquette it
pacetti you can see that income tax
rates have come down very sharply at the
very top and most of that get that
change by the way happens well before
the Bush tax cuts of 2001 for the broad
just middle of the distribution you can
see there has really been relative no
change in the average effective federal
tax rate so this this is a remarkable
change and it is worth quite a bit to
those at the very top in just between
the the Clinton tax rates of the 1990s
and 2007 the average effective income
tax rate paid by the top 400 taxpayers
which is a common metric the IRS puts
out decline from around thirty percent
to sixteen point five percent so when we
hear talk about paying say only a
fortune Mitt Romney paying only a
fourteen percent effective tax rate it's
actually not that uncommon among the
very richest taxpayers to pay something
on that scale so for the top four
hundred taxpayers their average income
tax rate went down from thirty percent
to sixteen point five percent over this
period that was worth about forty six
million dollars for every taxpayer in
that top four hundred group so each
taxpayer received a bit essentially at
four hundred six million dollars because
of the decline in tax rates just since
the mid-1990s and there was just a new
report out from the IRS showing that
these tax rates have continued to fall
particularly as more and more of the
income of those at the top is is
received in the form of capital gains
which is taxed at only fifteen percent
currently so according to new IRS data
the average income tax rate for
households with income above ten million
dollars that's about the point top point
one percent fell from twenty two point
four percent effective income tax rate
to about a twenty percent effect
income tax rate in 2010 nonetheless much
of the change that we're talking about
is before government taxes and benefits
and there's a tendency in the research
to assume that that portion of the
change in income must be a political
must have occurred without the influence
of government but if you think about it
for just a moment that's obviously a
very blinker view of the role of
government after all governments not
only tax and spend they also regulate
and shape the market in profound ways
and those way and those ways that they
do that can have an enormous effect on
the distribution of income in the market
even before governments visible hand
reaches in to tax or spend I made this
point in Paul and I made in the in the
book and I wrote a paper that I
presented in Britain and the young
aspiring Labour Party leader Miliband ed
Miliband was at the at the conference
and was taken by it and started talking
about it on the campaign trail and it so
happened that not within a relatively
short period of time I found myself the
subject of question time in here we are
did it die normally mr. speaker this
stage in the Proceedings I say in the
body of us it hasn't got any plans but
on this occasion I can reassure the
house they have got some bad plan it's
called pre distribution means is that
you spend the money before you actually
get it
mrs. bingo
I'll text words about is an economy is
that they call me that doesn't just work
for a few of the top the work is not
about a prime minister who cuts taxes
for millionaires while raising taxes
forever
he gets up to reply he can answer the
question which he so far hasn't answered
is he gonna be a beneficiary of the 50p
tax cut generated
I know you guys want to talk about Cree
distribution
Mr Speaker I can tell him about his new
guru his new guru is full I'm not making
this up the man who invented free
distribution he's cool he's gone our
minds I mr. they don't hear the border
house the border I was on both sides
each car now let's hear the premises on
you guru he's cool mr. Jay hacker his
recommendation is that we spend an extra
200 billion and borrow an extra 200
billion in this Parliament recognition
but in the work I've done I discovered
his new book it is published by
princeton university press and is called
the road to nowhere
okay yes so another agate you know deep
engagement I received in the public
sphere so the the idea of pre
distribution is not has nothing to do
with either the labor or conservative
parties platforms but the idea is
basically that there are a lot of ways
in which government can shape the
distribution of market income and in the
book we talked about several areas from
corporate governance to financial
regulation to industrial relations I
think the best example is indeed
financial regulation and if we remember
the story of Sandy Weill will remember
that deregulation was a huge part of the
lead-up to the financial crisis and the
huge gains that happened at the top
there's still a large amount of debate
about the exact role of a financial
deregulation in the financial crisis but
there's been a number of important
pieces of work on this including this
paper by Thomas Philip on and Philip
reshef looking at the relationship
between financial deregulation and
relative wages in the financial industry
now the there are two things to note
here one is that if you see here this
relative wage which is the sort of
oranges red line here that the that it
tracks almost perfectly the the u-shaped
trajectory of the top one percent over
the course of the 20th century that is
there was a large decline in the
relative wage and Finance after the New
Deal regulations and the stock market
crash and then over the last 20 years or
so 30 years or so with a hand in hand
with financial regulation there's been
an increase in the relative wage in
finance what the relative wages is
basically what simile educated and
skilled workers earn in finance relative
to workers and other fields and this is
just another way of saying that for a
long time people in finance didn't earn
a lot of money in the last generation
they have now this is a purely
correlational relation relationship here
but you can see here they also construct
an index of financial deregulation which
tracks the the rise and the financial
wage premium quite closely another
another thing that seems to track what
happened in Bitra deregulation is
financial instability if you look here
and this is from David Moss of the
Harvard Business School there's a lot
more going on this is the share of
income going to the top 10% it's very
similar to in terms of its trajectory to
the share of income going to the top 1%
or that wage premium I just showed you
and then these blue in these red lines
are just various measures of financial
instability total bank failures or the
total deposits have failed in assisted
institutions as a share of GDP and
that's reveal it's revealing that the
New Deal reforms seem to put an end to
the repeated endemic financial crises
that it occurred prior to the Great
Depression and it's only in the last 30
years in line with deregulation that
we've seen more financial instability
culminating in the financial crisis of
2008 and nine you'll see here that
because of the increasing consolidation
of the financial sector that actually
bank failures are not actually very high
this is a savings and loan crisis we're
far more banks failed but the deposits
of course under under the assets under
of failed institutions of course are
enormous and the the the financial story
is a huge part of the story of what's
happened to the top point one percent in
fact if you look at the tax records of
this rarified group you'll find that
about six and ten or corporate or
financial executives about two and ten
our financial executives about six and
ten four and ten or corporate executives
so corporate governance is another part
of the story that we tell in each of
these areas the changes were tied up
very much with the increasing role of
Finance which in turn was a parsley a
reflection of shifts in public policy
bipartisan shifts i should add that i'll
talk about in just a moment now part of
this was about changing policy and so
you saw major regulatory changes over
this period but in fact a lot of it was
simply about failing to update policy in
the face
of changing market structures and that's
another way in which public policy and
politics can play an important role in
shaping the distribution that we don't
pay much attention to in the book we
call this drift and drift is simply when
putt when the world changes but policy
doesn't in ways that are intended by key
actors and drift is most notable and
most and most political in many ways
when it involves the blocking activity
of very powerful private actors and this
was certainly the story in finance
there's a great moment or great moment
for us in the debate over accounting law
changes when the head of the SEC went to
the then chair of the Banking Committee
phil gramm and asked for some updates of
policy graham looked at him and I'm not
going to try to do the Texas accent and
said unless the waters are crimson with
the blood of investors I don't want you
engaging in any regulatory flights of
fancy so here was a clear case in which
a very powerful private actor situated
private political actor was standing in
the way of regulatory updating we see
this again and again over this period
because the the industry interests were
so much more energized and organized
around these issues look at Sandy while
putting so much more money into politics
than they ever had and we're so much
more capable of taking advantage of the
increasing and capacity of American
political institutions to act on a lot
of issues and that's that's I'm going to
move now to talking about some of the
larger political changes that took place
so of my 33 opening questions what was
the what was the nature of the change
what were some of the policies have
played a role and why did government do
it what what were the political what's
the political story behind it I want to
turn to this last question before
offering some broader reflections so if
the if the winner-take-all economy if
this rise was made substantially in
Washington that really raises a
fundamental puzzle it's it's again easy
to see why government will often cater
to large majorities that are
hence in their preferences but it's
harder to think about why would you get
policies over a long period of time that
were had such a concentrated set of
beneficiaries how could this happen in a
democracy that's so often seen is so
responsive to middle-class concerns you
know we can see some politics um and I
think one of the aspects of it that I
think we have to understand is that it's
been harder and harder as i was just
hinting for our political institutions
to act at all and perhaps the most
important reason for that is the rise of
the senate filibuster now for all of
those who've seen mr. Smith goes to
Washington we have this image in her
mind of the filibuster as this great
story to institution where senators go
to the floor and debate for hours on end
at the time that this movie was made the
filibuster was actually extremely rare
and it did take this form that was not
used usually by by people seeking such
lofty ends as mr. Smith was but by
southern racist seeking to prevent civil
rights legislation but nonetheless it
was rarely used and it was used
typically by intense minorities that
were willing to pay the price of going
to the floor and debating for long long
periods of time that has changed
dramatically the filibuster and this is
cloture filings to end Senate
filibusters as you can see it was
relatively rare up until this period of
that we've seen this last generation and
you can see that it's even concentrated
within that period really over the last
few years so uh since the if you look at
the 40 years before nineteen seventy
there were fewer than 40 cloture filings
across that entire period in the 40
years after there's been more than 800
cloture filings and just the two the
four years leading up to 2010 there were
more than 200 cloture filings alone and
that's shown no sign of declining in the
last two years I should note it if you
have any question James Madison you know
we tend to think of this as a
constitutional and aspect of our
constitutional government but the
filibuster is really an aspect of Senate
rules that has no mention in the
Constitution and
fact really runs against the grain of
many of the majoritarian sentiments of
the founders here's James Madison saying
that with the exception of a few areas
designed to sort of create separate
institutions sharing powers like the
veto having the majority be overruled by
the minority violated the fundamental
principle of free government and the
root the result of this rise in the use
of the filibuster both reflects and has
embedded rising partisan polarization
within Congress about which I'm sure
you've heard a lot I'll show you just
one result of that this is a number of
laws passed per session of Congress and
you can see that that this last Congress
really stands out in fact I think it's
the least productive Congress since the
middle of the late of the last of the
19th century just by way of comparison
that's to do nothing Congress that Harry
Truman talk to that it has 903 laws as
compared with about 170 in the last
Congress so in action is an important
important part of the story the sorry
the other aspect of the story about
which we heard a lot lately is the
transformation of the organized interest
environment around government and so
it's not just that it's harder for
political leaders to act but also that
they're facing much greater organized
pressure on many policy issues than they
were a generation ago the story we tell
in our book is really a bit of the sort
of massive counter mobilization of
organized corporate interest in the
1970s around issues of regulation there
was a real backlash in the corporate
community against Ralph Nader and
against some of the really huge
regulatory changes that were pursued
under Richard Nixon such as the EPA and
that led into a major mobilization
around both lobbying and campaigns and I
mentioned lobbying first because
lobbying is where corporations really
put their money the typical company
spends about 10 to 10 times that spends
money on politics spends about 10 times
as much on lobbying as they do on
campaigns and they're spending a lot
more than they were a generation ago
they're also spending a lot more on
campaigns we've seen that in the last
election but sometimes it's forgotten
just how dramatic the shift has been in
real dollars it's remarkable how little
was being spent on elections 20 or 30
years ago now in this last in this last
election and I think in 2008 you could
argue that a lot of the money was used
for ends that we might support like
mobilizing voters the point is though
that the the role of money has
dramatically increased over this period
and the need to get it through various
means is much greater for politicians
than it has ever been and in both those
respects I think we could there's an
asymmetric effect on the two major
political parties and that's I think a
hugely important aspect of the political
debates today and of the debates that
was that that have and the policy
changes that led to to these shifts that
I've
talking about for the Republican Party
this dramatic transformation has been
the rise of money the rise of lobbying
the mobilization of the corporate
community has been emboldened right it
is pushed Republicans to identify more
strongly with many of their core
principles and policy goals most notably
tax cuts for the four Democrats the
changes have been much less clear and
much more cross pressuring because for
Democrats they have seen simultaneously
the rise in corporate lobbying and of
contributions coming from the business
sector but also have been torn between
that and their their dwindling labor
base which has lost enormous ground over
this period and so you see this I think
in a lot of things but perhaps most
notably you see it in the remarkable
asymmetry in the polarization of the two
parties now whenever we talk about
polarization I think we assume that it's
symmetrical because after all in
political science the assumption is that
the two parties are competing for the
middle and that the party that deviates
farthest from the center absent a shift
in where the middle is is going to lose
elections but in fact the most clear
implication of much of the research has
been done by political scientist is it
polarization has actually been quite
dramatically a cement symmetrical with
Republicans moving farther to the right
than Democrats have moved to the left
now I think thats related to the
remarkable shifts in the organizational
universe that I've been talking about
the decline of middle-class
organizations like labor unions and
cross class civic organizations the rise
of lobbying and corporate organization
but I think it's also notable that it's
probably driven also by the much
different kinds of activist basis within
the two parties and the better
effectiveness of the Republican Party it
if you look at say Grover Norquist or
America or the club for growth at using
sort of recruitment and certification
processing and auditing processes to try
to discipline Republican members of
Congress particularly through primaries
whatever the exact balance of
explanations we really see
it in the numbers and these numbers come
from a remarkable effort by two
political scientists Keith pool and
Howard Rosenthal to chart the
ideological landscape of American
politics based on members votes now I'm
going to use these numbers in it and a
somewhat I don't know if an orthodox is
the right way but to keep with that
metaphor it's perhaps not the most
kosher way to use these I'm going to
start with the levels of the average
levels in the 1970s for the for the two
parties and then look at how the parties
have evolved over the last 35 years or
so the reason why this is not entirely
kosher is that there is no natural base
for these numbers it turns out that over
the whole of congressional history that
the mean is zero and also they're hard
to compare over very long spans of time
although they try to anchor them with
members who are overlapping in time so
let me show you the numbers and you'll
you'll see that it really doesn't matter
because they could be off by a very
large order of magnitude and the story
would be the same okay so if you look at
house democrats they become about
twenty-two percent more liberal again
all the caveats House Senate Democrats
have become a little bit more liberal on
these DW nominate scores on the economic
dimension of American politics which is
the main dimension according to pool and
Rosenthal Senate Republicans on the
other hand have become about
seventy-three percent more conservative
according to this and it will not
surprise you to see a massive increase
in the conservative House Republicans if
you take these DW nominate scores and
map them on to congressional history you
get a figure that looks like this this
may be the single coolest figure that I
found in American politics it's also
completely unintelligible unless I
explain it but let me just tell you that
these different shades of red and blue
indicate how conservative the members
are this shows you entrances of new
cohorts so here you get a class of
moderate a sort of middle of the middle
of the Republican Road Republicans in
recent years you can see more and more
of the Republicans who come in have been
on the right side of the spectrum this
for example is Paul Ryan here who's a
very conservative Republican and you can
see the story
is not the same on the Democratic side
that is to say there has been much more
there have been many more centrist and
and sort of moderate left Democrats and
there have been centrist and moderate
right Republicans you can actually get
this figure enough if you're interested
I'll provide the link that goes all the
way back to the founding of Congress few
of us have any sense of what the
relative influx of wigs and Federalists
means today but for recent American
politics this picture tells us a lot it
tells us first of all these parties have
been remarkably well balanced and that
the Republican Party is seen since the
mid-1990s 1994 to be exact a very large
influx of very conservative Republicans
the political science sean thereal has
calculated that almost all of the
polarization of American politics this
is remarkable is due to what he calls
the Gingrich senators that is and we're
at the house and house Gingrich that
sorry all the polarization the Senate is
due to what he calls the Gingrich
senators which is actually conservative
House Republicans who've moved over to
the Senate side this is one reason and
then I promise I will wrap up and this
is one reason why those who say
gerrymandering couldn't play any role in
this story might be wrong because if the
house if the house is seating the very
conservative Republicans over to the
Senate or liberal democrats that's one
of the ways in which gerrymandering or
other house centroid explanations of
increased polarization might spill over
onto the Senate so the this polarization
raises a question of whether you see
something comparable in public opinion
and I'll just say that there is very
little sign of overall polarization of
the public that is dispur the dispersion
do not show a big increase in
polarization on social issues both sides
of the political spectrum have actually
moved substantially to the left over the
last generation on economic issues it's
a much more stable picture but we do see
and this is what I mentioned before
there is a conservative activist base
it's more intense than you see on the
Republican on the Democratic side of the
aisle and that
maybe an important part of the story but
I think it's an important part of the
story that actually brings us back to
the to the fundamental issue that I
raised before what we've seen over the
last generation is is a shift in policy
that has actually been in quite
inegalitarian right and equality has
gone up in the market in part because of
policy changes I've discussed and in
addition market changes in inequality
have not been matched by policy shifts
that have pushed back against that
rising inequality a lot of that has been
driven by an action rather than action
and a lot of that inaction is driven by
polarization and the rising increase in
the use of the filibuster and the reason
that I believe that this partisan story
is linked in many ways is that if you
start to look at public views about
inequality about public policy what you
find is a much more complex view than
you get from the kind of popular
accounts of of welfare state supporting
Democrats on the one hand and highly
conservative Republicans on the other
there's a there was a famous article in
the 19th in the in the 1960s that argued
that America's were operational kansara
philosophical conservatives and
operational liberals that is they were
philosophically worried about government
but loved everything that government did
and in fact you find even among tea
party supporters very strong support for
many core public programs at the same
time even among Democrats you find
concern that we're not addressing st.
some of the festering fiscal problems of
our country the point is that in many
ways I think the story of the last
generation is of politics that's been
pulled away from middle class and and
driven it increasingly by elite
activists the role of money in American
politics and perhaps most pervasive the
increasing and capacity of our political
system to act at all now this may sound
like an extremely depressing story but I
don't see it as that I think that if the
depressing story in many ways is the one
that we so often hear that this is only
a
globalization and technological change
that our government really can do very
little to deal with it if fluent
politics is a very important part of the
increasing strains facing middle class
Americans then politics can be part of
the solution as well I do not I do not
want to pretend that that addressing
these problems would be easy we're not
going to revamp our Constitution but I
think we could at least have a few clear
priorities that are drawn out of some of
the analysis that I've offered today
first we should be doing what we can to
reduce or resist barriers to policy
updating and I think filibuster reform
is an important part of that task second
we should be trying insofar as possible
to reduce the ability to translate money
into power the essence of American
democracy is as the two Roosevelts
famously said at different points in
time is the ideal of political equality
and that rests on having some do some
kinds of flood walls between the market
and democracy inequality in our society
is one thing having that inequality
translate into political inequality is
quite another and fine finally I think
and there's maybe a hopeful sign in this
last election that we should be striving
not necessarily for a more parliamentary
system even though that's what our
political structure has increasingly
become with unified parties fighting it
out but for a more majoritarian system
one in which the majority preferences on
things like higher tax cuts tax rates on
the very well-off should be able to
whenever possible and not inconsistent
with other critical rights dominate and
when you look at the polls what you find
is that for most Americans they do not
feel that the middle class has that kind
of influence a poll that was done at the
during the height of the fight over
health care and financial reform a time
when the government was really grappling
with issues of critical concern to
middle-class Americans I think drives
home the sense of cynicism that many
Americans feel you can see here that
when
whether government economic policies
that help large banks and financial
institutions a great deal fifty-three
percent of Americans agreed with that
but when asked if they were helping
middle-class people or small businesses
only about two percent of Americans
agreed a great deal so there's a sense
among many Americans the system is not
working well to represent the middle
class and I think that some of the
reforms that i'm talking about might
address that concern so thank you okay
I'm look looking forward to having some
questions and answers from jacob and i'm
going to ask jacob to repeat the
questions so that the people on the live
stream video will know what the question
was raised yes hi situation because it
strikes me that philosophically
conservators that operationally
liberally over the last few elections
that Americans are not really voting for
politicians who are actually going to
enact the policy preferences that they
themselves the electorate says that they
would like and I want to know to what
extent you think our causes of that what
is one is the ignorance of most
Americans about where basically where
tax money comes
the other thing is people voting for
candidates rather than increasingly
polarized good question okay so the
question is basically I see it as being
about to what extent is this due to
people not neither either not
recognizing or not voting on the basis
of their their interest and and to what
extent and how do we understand the
causes of that in our contemporary
political environment you know I mean
since Thomas Frank's what's the matter
with Kansas this may be like one of the
most common questions that I ever get
and and i think there's obviously some
truth to Frank's argument if you look at
working class Democratic voters the ones
who've been started working class white
voters who have been really battered by
the economy over the last generation
they've dropped their support for
Democrats has dropped by about 20
percentage points now we saw in this
last election that other voters can
offset that decline and support but it
raises some pretty fundamental questions
like what are they thinking right given
the priorities of the two parties and I
would just say that I want to make two
22 points I want to actually say that
first of all the the ignorance and lack
of information about policy or politics
is definitely nothing new in American
politics since we started doing polling
we've always been struck by how little
people know and and and and and there's
been ingenious arguments by political
scientist to argue that that doesn't
really matter because of the aggregation
properties of elections and also
because of the role of organizations and
elites and i think one part of the story
that i'm telling is really that those
kind of intermediate organizations that
once worked on a regular basis to try to
help people get engaged with political
issues and help them navigate political
debates have really atrophied and so we
see this most clearly of working-class
whites those who are members of unions
are much more likely to vote for
Democrats holding everything else
constant you might say well that's
obvious why they would because unions
the Democratic Party are closely aligned
but I think another thing is and we see
this in lots of studies and in
particular with turn out that unions
play an important mobilizing and
educated role whether we think unions
are the right institutions to do it they
are perhaps the only institution that
consistently did it for workers of
modest means over the last generation
but I would say and it's this is I think
really important that we don't overstate
the extent to which Americans are
expressing a set of views that are
highly consistent with these policy
outcomes and it's really a question of
understanding why it is that they come
to hold those views in fact if you look
across three or four major debates today
the priority of of trying to deal with
joblessness as opposed to the deficit
whether or not we should raise taxes on
the very top whether we should cut
Social Security and Medicare or the
military on each of those Americans want
to cut the military not so Security and
Medicare just you know on each of those
we actually see policy departing pretty
starkly from what the majority of
Americans say they want and you don't
have to there's a bunch of research
that's been done on this this is
probably the most interesting this comes
from a new book by Marty Guillen's what
he looks at is the probability that if a
policy is supported by different income
groups and he uses thousands of public
opinion polls whether it will actually
be enacted it subsequently the first
thing you should see here is that this
the top of this graph is 50% so even
things that have 90 nut you know
overwhelming support from the richest
most educated people do not clear the
fifty percent chance of getting past so
it's still a quick it's about a coin
flip
for things that are supported by this
group but what you can see here is that
there's a very clear gradient and he
does not suggest that this has changed
dramatically over time in the interest
of full disclosure and I'm he looks at
one earlier year and then most of his
data is from the last 20 years so so
it's not clear whether this has changed
but there this and worked by Larry
bartels of political science at
Vanderbilt that work suggested there's a
problem in middle class responsiveness
as well as a problem of middle-class
confusion and so I would think that the
first place to focus in in thinking
about how to make our political system
work better is to try to figure out why
it seems so weakly responsive even to
people in the middle of the income
distribution when their preferences are
not consistent with those at the top yes
right here since the election you know
when you kind of consider some of these
comments this was a measly reelection I
mean it was much more significant than w
reelection first of all for a half
million more popular horse so the other
side keeps on living in this alternate
reality or in this ignorant world and so
how are we going to gap this
disinformation I mean I
well I mean I think that so the question
is basically you know if conservatives
may be living in a bubble of their own
creation of late and ice and the
question is is that going to change and
there are certainly some very vocal
Republicans david from for example
who've argued that this is a big problem
in in some ways right the the way in
which our political system generally is
supposed to discipline parties is to it
when they lose elections they're forced
to sort of reckon with aspects of their
their stance that that are not popular
in this case i do think that around
issues of immigration and support of
hispanic voters there has been more
attention within the party for example
they immediately rushed out their
version of the DREAM Act which i think
is the achieve act right is it yours is
a dream and ours is an achievement but
um but on this central question about
sort of what's the stance that they
should take towards tax cuts they've
been they've been much more reluctant to
shift apparently the Republicans put out
an offer today for eight hundred billion
dollar in tax cuts over ten for
increased revenues over ten years
through unspecified deductions and
loopholes which is about half of what
the president is calling for but also i
think if you look at the ideas out there
for capping deductions is pretty
unrealistic especially if we're going to
preserve the charitable deduction so
it's really there's a good question of
whether or not the the party has seen
the writing on the wall in this in this
budget debate now the fact is the what
we would call in political science a
reversion point in the debate is all the
tax taxes that the bush tax cuts
disappear right so there's a pretty
strong mechanism for pressing them to
the table and i think that we'll see
we'll see much more movement of the
republicans i mean the president obama
has taken a fairly different stance in
this debate than he did in 2011 over the
debt ceiling i think they're probably
the biggest wild card right now with
regard to the fiscal debate
fiscal cliff debate is really whether or
not the Democrats can get the debt
ceiling issue resolved because that's
looming very soon in the future after
the fiscal cliff I think that the there
too if you looked at the polling the
internal polling of the Republicans they
really overstated there standing I mean
there's a lot of stories about this it's
not entirely clear how much they were
fooled and how much they were just
trying to fool the news media but it may
well be that that there's a real cost to
this kind of insularity at this
particular juncture but I think we
shouldn't we shouldn't forget that if
the forces that we're driving that shift
I was talking about we're not primarily
voter forces then the disciplining are
the sort of corrective mechanisms may be
fairly weak so if it is indeed that
Grover Norquist and his no new taxes
pledge may loom much larger for these
Republicans then say swing voters then
it's going to be a while and it's going
to be a tough tough and difficult
process and it would probably take you
know it's probably going to take more
electoral battle scars and and you know
we'll see what happens midterm elections
have played out very differently than
presidential elections over the last
decade or so much smaller more
conservative electorate tends to be more
white and older and so and Republicans
have also done fairly well insulating
themselves in the house they have them
they got a you know slim minority of the
popular vote but managed to pretty
handily hold on to all of their seats so
there's a degree to which that House
Republican caucus is going to be pretty
entrenched for some time to come Yeah
right there yeah
and yet there's all this discussion in
the current debate about changing the
top grades from 36 to 39 etc but it
seems like almost all those people could
not be pain so one thing is of course
tap again yeah that's a big thing the
other thing is structures in the tax
code that only they can avail themselves
of so I haven't heard that mention and
what I'm worried about is there's going
to be a huge sell out where you know
they're going to you know unfairly
wealthy doctors and professors your
toxins are going to go up right and the
people that are the super routes that
you're emphasizing they're actually
monopolizing the resources it'll just
why under the radar because you know
they they won't raise the capital gains
rate it's a good good concern so the
question is basically in the current
policy debate we're talking about
raising the top two tax rates obviously
those tax rates are paid you know by
four on every dollar of income above the
the the filing threshold so it would it
would hit those in the top point one
percent relatively hard but it wouldn't
hit the top point one percent as hard as
some other changes that really really
dealt with some of the special
provisions that seem to be worth the
most to the very very well-off and the
two most important that were mentioned
were the capital gains / via the low
rate on capital gains I would also
mention dividends both of which date
from the bush tax cuts actually the
capital gains tax came down 1986 Reagan
sets capital gains tax at the same rate
as the tax on labor income it's a
remarkable moment right it's actually
historically there's been a lower rate
on capital gains but in 1986 as part of
a compromise we basically tax capital
gains as ordinary income in 1997 it came
down today it's and then again in the
bush tax cuts today it is fifteen
percent and this has a Remora I mean it
has a much larger effect and you might
think because the change in the who's at
the top is real
important as I said six and ten to the
top point one percent are corporate and
financial executives these are people
who have enormous amount of influence
over the form their compensation takes
right and so they're shoving more and
more of it into capital gains as you
would if your Chapel gains as being
taxed at fifteen percent the hedge fund
managers are a special case because of
an interpretation of the tax code that
is clearly wrong but needs let
legislative change to be altered they
get to treat much significant share of
their earnings basically money that's
under management but not their own the
fees they get from that as capital gains
in this pay if I fifteen percent tax
rate as well so the question was really
is there why isn't there more discussion
of a focus on sort of that that those
particular things and I would say they
state and the gift tax for another
aspect of it and I would just say
something I think is very little
recognized is that in most of the recent
tax cut debates the story you tell which
is sort of basically trying to shift the
burden from the stinking rich to the
ordinary Ridge has been a big part of
Republicans aims and you might say it's
either you could say it's driven by this
need to build a kind of money base for
the party or it could be driven by the
conviction that these are the job
creators and risk takers whatever the
reason in the debate over the estate tax
in the in the Korean in taking the
opportunity after the 2002 midterm to
add the identity of these cases these
were very concentrated benefits like
economic smart bombs for the very very
very well-off and so the reverse that
would require I think there need to be
two things one would be a serious reform
of the capital gains tax treatment and
and I think you know I think you could
find common ground here around the idea
that that we should have spent maybe
special treatment of long-term capital
gains but a lot of capital gains is
essentially just income in another you
no ordinary labor income in another form
and it was worth noting that the
president that in the Republicans and
saying we want 800 billion in loophole
closing and explicitly ruling out tax
rate increases are ruling out the
president's increase in the capital
gains tax in his he does tax carried
interest and his proposed 1.6 trillion
dollar proposal and in the estate and
gift tax which
you want to return to the 2009 levels so
this is really in some ways what the
debate is about but the president's
proposal according to tax policy center
would raise about half of its total 1.6
trillion from the top point one percent
and about 75% from the top 1% if you did
a deduction cap that was at the level it
would be required to raise 1.6 trillion
which is I think going to be below
$25,000 itemized deduction cap maybe
seventeen thousand dollars essentially
you would have about a quarter paid by
the top 0.1% and about a half paid by
the top 1% and a lot would be paid by
the sort upper middle class right
because there's no way there's just not
enough deductions and credits at the
very top so I actually am surprised the
extent to which this has not been a kind
of talking point I think the president
is trying to avoid making this seem like
oh you know raising taxes on those at
the top is is you know a form of you
know class warfare or fight but the
truth is is that the the Republicans are
in standing for this idea that loophole
closing is the only way you can raise
revenue are in fact really holding are
really protecting the very very well-off
and probably that's where I have to end
okay Jacob thank you very much for this
illuminating and interesting discussion
and I'd like to invite you all to join
us at a reception in the common room
next door and to join us in September
and march and april for the next three
lectures in this series thank you for
coming